foreign
on this Wednesday night hockey Quebec
Powers forward without Hockey Canada the
Ripple effects of severing ties with a
national governing body and the
amplifying calls for accountability why
for four years did this feminist
government or I should say so-called
feminist government do abs absolutely
nothing
Ukrainian troops reclaim more regions
from Russia
as the Kremlin claims it will retake
what's been lost democracy and the
deniers claims of a stolen U.S election
blanket the November midterm elections
and historic home run
the baseball player who slugged a
six-decade old record
[Music]
National with Donna Friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the pressure is mounting on the senior
leadership at Hockey Canada after a
combative day being grilled by MPS in
Ottawa and refusing to make any changes
there are signs the organization is
beginning to crumble hockey Quebec is
turning its back on the national
governing body and both the federal
Sports Minister and the Prime Minister
say it's time for the organization to
clean house
it boggles the mind uh that Hockey
Canada is continuing to dig in its heels
parents across the country are losing
faith or have lost faith in hockey
Canada certainly uh politicians here in
Ottawa have lost faith in hockey Canada
um it's no surprise that provincial
organizations are questioning whether or
not they want to continue supporting an
organization that doesn't understand how
serious a situation it has contributed
to causing
the lack of faith is spreading late
today confirmation from Tim Hortons one
of the organization's biggest sponsors
it will pull sponsorship of all of the
men's hockey programs from the upcoming
season all of this stems from Hockey
Canada's handling of alleged sexual
assaults and the way money was paid out
in lawsuits but now it goes even deeper
into the culture and Leadership of the
entire organization Mike Armstrong has
our top story tonight
The Fallout from Hockey Canada's various
scandals is having an impact it would
appear at many levels just tear it down
start all over from parents in parking
lots to politicians in Parliament I
think we need meaningful change at the
top of Hockey Canada
Tuesday's appearance by Hockey Canada's
new interim chair has gone over a little
like a lead balloon Andrea Skinner was
criticized for resistance to change and
there's also some frustration over one
line in particular she questioned
whether hockey in Canada could survive
without Hockey Canada and its leadership
team
will the lights stay on on the rink I
don't know we can't we can't we can't
predict that and to me that's not a risk
worth taking
well the hearing appears to have been
that one last straw for hockey Quebec
just hours later the organization's
board voted on a resolution stating it
has lost confidence in the National
Federation and is withholding the funds
it normally gives to Hockey Canada
that's a three dollar fee collected for
every member at every age
Quebec's President says he's going to be
keeping the money in a trust and will
wait to see if change comes but
basically Claude faktan says he's tired
of hearing complaints
he says it's not fun he was at a
tournament over the weekend and almost
everyone who walked up to him talked
about Hockey Canada now other provincial
organizations are weighing the same move
and there is pressure the federal Sports
Minister says Hockey Canada doesn't
belong to its board it belongs to its
members those members she says should be
insisting on change since the leaders of
Hockey Canada are holding on to their
jobs the voting members need to clean
the house
now there's no date yet but the Heritage
committee does know who it wants to hear
from next Bob Nicholson now with the
Edmonton Oilers for more than 15 years
he was the president and CEO of Hockey
Canada he's been sent to subpoena to
force him to appear no it's not normal
that's something the committee doesn't
usually do but members say they made the
move faced with an unwillingness by
Hockey Canada to answer questions
otherwise
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
Hockey Canada had its Federal funding
Frozen in June after the Scandal about
multi-million dollar payouts to settle
sexual assault lawsuits it received
roughly 7.8 million dollars or six
percent of its annual budget from the
federal government within our hockey
crazed Nation Hockey Canada a non-profit
organization sits at the top it's the
governing body of 13-member branches in
every corner of the country these
entities like hockey Quebec manage
Amateur Hockey at the provincial
Regional and territorial level hockey
Canada also partners with 12 affiliate
organizations like the CHL the NHL and
the International Ice Hockey Federation
in what they call an effort to grow the
game in its latest annual report the
organization said it had more than 385
thousand players registered under its
umbrella that number is said to be lower
than usual because of the pandemic
now to Russia's war in Ukraine the
Kremlin vows it will retake any
territory it has lost to advancing
Ukrainian forces and says it intends to
declare the zaparisian nuclear plant
Russian property a fresh wave of Russian
conscripts is being sent to the front
but as Crystal gemancing Reports
Ukrainian forces are still making Fast
and strong gains where it counts
with rubble still smoldering Air Raid
Sirens whale warning of more attacks
Wednesday
this 80 year old who lives across the
street from the strike heard a roaring
piercing sound then another Roar
followed by a boom it's been weeks since
the area around the Ukrainian Capital
was hit the governor of Kiev oblast
posted on telegram that so-called
Kamikaze drones were used six strikes
injuring one person and damaging
infrastructure
possibly a sign of Russian frustration
Ukraine is challenging Russia and
breaking through its front lines in the
East and the South
reclaiming territory at a rapid pace
Russia however continues to claim it is
seeing Battlefield successes and is now
laying claim to Europe's largest nuclear
plant Vladimir Putin declared it would
be supervised by Russia since it's
located in a region recently annexed
albeit illegally by the Kremlin Putin
did walk back on a decree outlining who
must participate in Russia's invasion of
Ukraine Putin announced deferred
conscription for some such as students
attending private accredited
universities it comes as tens of
thousands of men of fighting age have
been fleeing to neighboring countries
including Georgia after a mobilization
order was issued September 21st
with the war entering its eighth month
life in Ukraine is unrecognizable even
in reclaimed regions there is still
suffering
ten-year-old ludmina sarodnick describes
where the furniture used to be in his
family's home in a village in the
Donetsk gold blast fighting back tears
he says now it's almost no Home
Crystal gemancing Global News London
a former Russian journalist famous for
staging an on-air protest against
Putin's invasion of Ukraine says she's
escaped house arrest
says she decided to escape house arrest
because she's innocent she says Putin
should be wearing an ankle monitor not
her she was given two months house
arrest for standing up and calling the
Russian president a murderer she also
faces charges of spreading fake news she
failed to turn up at her hearing today
Russia has now declared her a fugitive
in March ospanyakova stormed the set of
one of Russia's most popular news
programs with a poster reading stop the
war
U.S President Joe Biden visited
hurricane ravaged Florida and promised
more federal aid for the huge rebuilding
effort
everything everything is historic
Titanic and unimaginable storm just
ripped it to pieces and it's going to
take a lot a lot of time not weeks or
months it's going to take years for
everything to get squared away
Biden was joined by Governor Ron
DeSantis a frequent critic of his and
potential Republican presidential
candidate they met with residents and
small business owners in Fort Myers the
death toll in Florida has risen to at
least 110 and rescue crews are still
searching flooded neighborhoods the
damage is estimated to top 100 billion
dollars
it's already been almost two years since
Biden was elected and that means the U.S
midterms are approaching it will be a
big test of his leadership and
Republicans are hoping the November 8th
vote will change the game for them lots
of Americans continue to believe the lie
that the 2020 election was stolen 60
percent of Voters live in districts
where so-called election deniers are
actually on the ballot our Jackson
prosco is in Pennsylvania tonight
looking at the implications of the big
election lie
in the birthplace of American democracy
Donald Trump's election lies are on the
ballot here Republican candidates for
every level of office question the
legitimacy of the 2020 election
denialism is is very strong in
Pennsylvania and across the country our
electoral process is being challenged
Tremaine Daniels is the Democratic
candidate in Pennsylvania's 10th
District her opponent is incumbent
Republican Congressman Scott Perry a
central figure in Trump's plot to
overturn the election on January 6th
Perry's phone was recently seized by the
FBI they denied the results of the Biden
election they don't deny the results of
their own elections so their election
denial is very specific if we can't
trust the vote there really are no
winners Republican strategist Charlie
Giro insists there's nothing wrong with
candidates questioning election
Integrity he claims the party has moved
on from Trump's big lie most voters are
not focused on what may or may not have
happened on January 6th they're looking
forward but listen to Doug mastriato the
Republican candidate for Pennsylvania
Governor as our election was compromised
mastriano was in the crowd at the
Capitol on January 6th and is still
pushing conspiracy theories and lies
about 2020. revenge is part of his
platform as your Governor I get to
appoint the Secretary of State and guess
who oversees elections I do through the
Secretary of State it's not just
Pennsylvania so-called election deniers
are on the ballot in a majority of the
States including dozens of candidates
for Statewide jobs like governor and
attorney general positions with
oversight of how elections are conducted
[Music]
in Arizona Republican gubernatorial
candidate Kerry lake is a full-blown
denier
in Michigan conspiracy theorist
Christina caramo is the Republican
nominee for Secretary of State let's
make Michigan's elections honest again
it's all a sign of Donald Trump's
continued grip on the Republican Party
making November a stress test for how
free and fair the 2024 presidential
election will be where there is a debate
about whether elections are stolen or
not that is no benefit to either party
in my opinion in the long run there's
little debate this is a precarious
moment for American democracy when one
of only two parties on the ballot is so
deeply committed to claiming that
elections cannot be trusted
Jackson prosco Global News Philadelphia
British prime minister Liz truss tried
to salvage her reputation at the
conservative party conference today
facing dire opinion polls after her
wildly unpopular economic agenda trust
gave a speech promising growth and said
her tough approach will pay off
this Mission will be difficult
but it is necessary
we have no alternative if we want to get
our economy moving again
I'm ready to make the hard choices
Her speech was interrupted by protesters
waving a banner that said who voted for
this trust has been on the defensive
since her first days in office and has
backtracked on an unpopular tax cut for
the rich
Believe It or Not thanksgiving's Just
Around the Corner coming up why it won't
be a feast with all the trimmings for
some Canadians
[Music]
it's a grim reality in the world right
now income inequality inflation and
interest rates are all Rising as
Canadians plan Thanksgiving dinner some
will be adjusting what's on the menu and
gaviola explains
yeah
your plans for turkey with all the
fixings may need a rethink all the
classics will cost noticeably more this
year from pumpkin pie to potatoes and
cranberries Dairy produce meat and baked
goods are high up on the list nearly a
quarter of Canadians say they're making
changes to the menu this Thanksgiving
because of food inflation this is
happening most in lower income
households with nearly a third cutting
back and most common in BC at 29 percent
Alberta 25 percent
there are a lot of reasons for the jump
in cost inflated gas prices that feed
through to everything we get trucked or
shipped in Russia's invasion of Ukraine
Europe's spread basket along with
climate impacts to agriculture on a
world scale the war in Ukraine is
disrupting wheat and seed oil markets
and then there's been a drought in many
different parts of the world in the U.S
California in particular and that's
reducing supplies of fresh produce
drought conditions in California hit us
in the pocketbook hard because we import
a lot of Fresh Foods grown there throw
in a global labor shortage and prices
are steeper for anything that needs to
be processed the list goes on poultry
producers are dealing with a spike in
avian flu outbreaks hitting farmers in
Alberta and Saskatchewan an avian flu is
a bird uh virus and it affects the bird
populations Health Canada assures us
that it's not a food safety issue though
bird flu is not transmissible to humans
it means less Supply and extra effort
may be needed to find that fresh bird
you may have to go to another store to
find one the fresh Supply may be
challenging at times depending on what
store you're going to or a localized
suppliers to keep a lid on costs you can
buy local choose canned or frozen fruits
and vegetables and reduce the amount of
meat you purchase maybe choosing a
smaller Frozen bird is in the cards for
you and yours this year while bumping up
those side dishes and gaviola Global
News Toronto
the gig is up ahead Jason kenney's
Legacy as Alberta's premier
in just over 24 hours Alberta will have
a new premier Jason Kenney is leaving
forced out by the United conservative
party he formed Kenny had a long run in
federal politics before he was elected
Premier but his popularity quickly waned
as Heather urich's West explains the 54
year old says he is leaving political
life with no regrets
it's been the privilege of a lifetime to
be able to serve calgarians and
albertans with his time as the premier
of Alberta coming to an end Jason Kenney
is looking back over a political career
that spanned more than 25 years to be
styled minister of employment and Social
Development first elected to the federal
House of Commons at age 29 he quickly
Rose through the ranks to hold several
key positions within Prime Minister
Stephen Harper's cabinet just incredibly
energetic articulate and ambitious I
mean he he always has been somebody that
just wanted to get things done and uh
you know he wasn't prepared to go along
with the status quo but in 2016 after
the defeat of the Harper government
Jason Kenney said his sights on Alberta
politics working to unite the province's
two right-wing political parties and
eventually winning the leadership of the
new United conservative party
Kenny's UCP government cruised to an
easy majority but his honeymoon was
short-lived his popularity was already
beginning to wane when the world was hit
with covet 19. it was his handling of
covid a very very significant questions
about the wisdom of some of the policies
promising the best summer ever and then
going on vacation at a time that that
Alberta was struggling with the highest
case numbers facing a polarized
electorate and party members who felt
betrayed Jason kenney's support entered
a free fall I had a perhaps naive
approach to
caucus relations and that is perhaps the
closest thing Jason Kenney has to regret
during covid Kenny frequently pivoted
between speaking for and against public
health measures I wonder if perhaps we
owed albertans a greater degree of
discipline and coherence thank you for
coming a rare admission from a leader
who didn't often back down as he looks
towards a new chapter outside political
life Heather York's West Global News
Calgary
a settlement has been reached in the
lawsuit between Alec Baldwin and the
family of Helena Hutchins she was killed
last year by a prop gun fired by Baldwin
while filming the movie rust the suit
alleged there were safety violations on
the set production of rust is expected
to begin again in January Baldwin and
four others could still face criminal
charges over her death
a home run for the history books next
the New York Yankee who just became
baseball's latest Legend
Sports history has been made in
Arlington Texas New York Yankees Slugger
Aaron judge knocked his 62nd home run
this season out of the park smashing a
decades-old record for most home runs in
a single American League season it is an
achievement that has cemented judge's
name as one of baseball's all-time
greats Eric Sorensen has more
All Eyes in baseball have been following
Aaron judge for months a week ago
Canadian fans were there to witness
history judges 61st home run equaled a
record that stood for six decades but it
was a mere Prelude to this the greatest
home run season in the 122-year history
of the American League judge is a giant
on the field at six foot seven but his
humility is just as impressive as he
took in his biggest moment in the sport
I just think of my wife thinking of my
family you know
my teammates you know just the fans
judge may have been subdued but watch
the Yankees radio announcer swung on
there it goes deep left it is high that
is far and is gone and the lucky guy who
got the ball and his teammates who
erupted and fans in Texas who were
ecstatic I'm still on cloud nine this is
unbelievable some records look
unbreakable Joe DiMaggio's hitting
streak Nolan Ryan's strikeouts Cal
ripken's Iron Man record and then there
is the single season home run record a
most hallowed achievement but the
records were set in the era of steroid
use and are not recognized as legitimate
by many baseball purists which brings us
to the Yankees and the historic home run
numbers that have meant so much to
baseball 95 years ago Babe Ruth's record
60 home runs 34 years later Roger Maris
is 61 for a Time baseball added a little
asterisk just because the season was
longer and now Aaron judge no asterisks
no whiff of Scandal Lord drugs 62 home
runs making history with one game to
spare judge has extolled the Integrity
of Ruth and Maris because he says they
played the game the right way we're
getting a chance to have my name next to
you know someone as great as Roger
Mary's Babe Ruth those guys is
incredible records have always mattered
in baseball veteran writers have kept
suspected steroid users out of the
Sports Hall of Fame judge plays in an
ERA with regular drug testing
greatest home run season
in
steroid related in baseball history the
fan who caught the ball hasn't said what
he'll do with it it could be worth two
million dollars and judge a free agent
this winter will command hundreds of
millions but more important than money
for many fans Aaron judge has restored
an unconditional joy for one of
baseball's most cherished Records Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Autumn setting in on
Christopher Lake Saskatchewan we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]